hey all jimmy thing here I got a chance
to go visit valve HQ to get some
hands-on time with artifact the
company's trading card game what you're
seeing is the second time I've played a
match the people talking behind me are
the developers the game is like
hearthstone but uses heroes from dota
and incorporate some MOBA like elements
for instance there are three lanes you
play through them sequentially from left
to right and it kind of feels like
you're playing three mini matches at
once each lane has a tower that you need
to destroy and to win you have to be the
first to destroy two towers it's pretty
fun check it out
so this deck is gonna be more
challenging to play in the early game
your heroes are more likely to die or
early because they're just generally
weaker two characteristic of the blue
and the green cards but there's a
trade-off which is that you're gonna hit
really hard late-game sort of like the
AI was doing - you wouldn't Eclipse and
thunder God's wrath and spells like that
so you can look through the cards in
your hand if you double-click thunder
God's wrath that's a really good one to
see what you're not like
it's expensive but it is a lot of damage
to every enemy hero in every Lane I
can't I can't even use this one yet
right you'll have no blue hero in the
light Oh Jane you're all right so
there's nothing I can do right now
besides attack yes you'll probably want
to use that little late oh my cute wait
so he buffed bristle back in order to
kill you're like ouch so that's kind of
what I was talking about this risk of
losing your heroes earlier with the blue
cards but it's made up for by your
ability to hit hard later and losing or
early isn't really that big of a deal
because of your ability to redeploy them
where you want them to be okay so that
card you were looking at Frost by it
yeah this might be a good opportunity to
use it okay I'll think about it who do
you want to use it on probably want to
use it on enemy oh okay guys yeah
okay so you just flip this combat around
it did two damage to her
so that means Lunas three damage is
gonna kill sore leçon and it also
disarmed her so now she can't hit Luna
so you were gonna die now you're not
gonna die
they weren't gonna die now they are
gonna die so that's a pretty pretty
awesome all right doesn't look like this
in cars I can deploy right now
[Music]
and see if we can buy
and Zeus will be coming up for
deployment
yes I put him over here it's kind of
risky if he lands right in front of
Brussels back he might just feed these
guys I can put over there though so
those two guys are your melee creeps and
we shuffle into the board to melee
creeps each turn they're going to go
into the middle lane okay so you could
put Zeus in the third Lane and just wait
a little bit on that first Lane okay and
we don't want to just have him go there
to die is that we were saying it might
be good because he blocks the ten damage
they will block through the tower
yeah I'll block ten damage but it's
gonna make bristle back stronger Russell
back gets two armor for every hero he
eats I see alright it's your call
so we'll just do one more round of
filming violation ready to pick refine
can't use it yeah that's nice to have in
the future okay that's all I can do this
right now right right I'm Brady Brady
Pete is hitting your tower hard so yeah
next turn won't want to bring in some
presents here oh is it really hard why I
thought I was supposed to be the carry
in this game yeah
[Music]
I can't use this one it costs five do I
want to use any of these the leather
armor perhaps I think you might want to
save it
[Music]
and here you would kill a kid at you
come on you can use your dimensional
portal to some of the bunch of blockers
nice thing about this the creator had to
change her target do I want to equip
other armor here but since how that
could be good yeah maybe either one
either one and it is permanent so you
have addresses of the game can I use it
on creep - or they just don't know they
don't have equipment slots okay so he's
got seven he's asking
I'll need to be ready for president
now we go to the dice America shopping
you
you